ودعونا نتحدث عن هذا
القتال العنيف ، ما الذي يمكن أن تخبرنا به عن
خسارة القوات ، وفي الواقع رد روسيا ،
نيك
، أعتقد أنه كان مجرد سيناريو لمرة واحدة
حيث سمعنا عن نوع من
عدد الضحايا الروس المرتفع أه
والنقد  من قيادة الضباط
ومحاولة رفع العلم مرة أخرى في أه
تعلمون مرة أخرى مع السياسيين في
بقية أنحاء روسيا ،
فهناك احتمال أن
يتم استبعاده كما تعلمون على أنه
انحراف ولكن هذا لا
يتماشى مع الانتقادات التي لديها
تطفو على السطح خاصة منذ أن
دعا الرئيس بوتين أه إلى هذا
التجنيد منذ حوالي شهر أو نحو ذلك ،
قال الآن إن هناك أكثر من 80
ألف أه دربوا أكثر من 50000
من هؤلاء المجندين في الخطوط الأمامية
لكن السرد المتسق وهذا هو
الأمر الذي تم تضخيمه في هذه الرسالة
حول فقدان أو موت أو إصابة أكثر من
300 من مشاة البحرية هو أن القوات تصل
إلى خط المواجهة ولا يتم
إبلاغها بشكل كافٍ إلى أين
يذهبون  ليس لديهم المعدات المناسبة ،
ليس لديهم ذخيرة كافية ،
ليس لديهم أسلحة كافية ، ليس لديهم
خوذات واقية كافية ، بعض
سترات الطيران ، كما يتماشى مع ما
نسمعه من القوات الأوكرانية التي
تخبرنا بذلك  يرون هؤلاء المجندين الجدد
يُجبرون على هؤلاء
المجندين الروس الجدد يُجبرون على الخطوط
الأمامية ويمكنهم القول إنك تعرف
هذه القوات الأوكرانية التي
تشهد هذا أو تجربة في
خط المواجهة ويمكنهم رؤية هؤلاء
المجندين الروس على الجانب الآخر
كونهم يفتقرون إلى الخبرة فهم
يشاهدونهم بطائرات بدون طيار ولا يعرفون كيف
يتصرفون على جبهة القتال هو ما
قاله لنا أحد الجنود الأوكرانيين
وهم يرون هؤلاء المجندين الجدد يتم
استخدامهم كعلف للمدافع تم إرساله
إلى الأمام من قبل جيش خاص أكثر احترافًا.
المرتزقة المتعاقدون إذا رغبت
في ذلك من مجموعة فاجنر المرسلة من
قبلهم لإلقاء الضوء حقًا على مكان وجود
القوات الأوكرانية حيث
تطلق القوات الأوكرانية النار على  يتقدم المجندون
إلى الأمام مما يعطيهم
موقع إطلاق النار لكن الأوكرانيين يقولون
إنهم يستطيعون رؤية الجثث تتراكم ،
لذا فإن الصورة التي تظهر
هي صورة متسقة أن جبهة القتال هذه في
الوقت الحالي ساخنة للغاية كما
نعرفها في الأوكرانية  الجانب هناك
ضحايا أيضا هناك
معركة مكثفة للغاية في الوقت الحالي
ولكن من الجانب الروسي ، فإن
الخسائر تصيب الأوكرانيين في
الوقت الحالي.